foreign  [Music]  so I have some very exciting news for  you I'm back with a new film profile  made after the Fujifilm maternal  simulation I've been very busy lately  and had very little time on hand but I  really wanted to make this video to  share with you these settings and how  you can get the same look using the  creative Lots also I will show you how  to replicate the cinesteel 800 look so  watch the whole video to find out how a  little bit about the profile I'm  absolutely in love with the profile it's  just gorgeous in terms of contrast and  how Adventures colors I've been testing  it for a week or two in multiple  scenarios and lighting conditions and